esta vez tenemos tres funciones aquí y
lo que quiero que hagamos juntos es
pensar para cada una de estas funciones
si son pares o impares y solamente con
un pequeño repaso recuerda que una
función para una función par es aquella
que tiene la propiedad de que f de menos
x es exactamente lo mismo que f de x es
decir es lo mismo poner menos x en la
función que poner x en la función y para
una función impar déjame ponerlo aquí
para una función impar lo que se cumple
es que f de menos x es exactamente lo
mismo que menos f
qué menos efe de x se ingresa menos x a
la función te va a dar lo mismo que el
negativo de ingresar a x en la función y
bueno recuerda que también puede ser que
tengas una función que no sea par ni sea
impar que no sea ninguna de estas dos
posibilidades entonces bueno probemos
con estas tres funciones que tengo aquí
así que empecemos con hdx y como siempre
te encargo que pausa el vídeo y vea si
tú puedes resolverlo por tu cuenta
ok vamos a hacerlo vamos a evaluar h
déjame ponerlo aquí h de menos x y bueno
sabemos que hd menos x por la definición
de h va a ser exactamente lo mismo que
menos 10 que multiplica a menos x esto
elevado a la potencia 11 más menos x
esto elevado a la potencia de 9 - menos
x
esto elevado a la potencia 3 y después
más 7 que multiplica a menos x muy bien
ahora bien cuánto es menos x elevado a
la potencia 11 bueno como la potencia 11
es impar menos equis elevado a la
potencia 11 va a ser lo mismo que el
negativo de x elevado a la potencia 11
ya que aquí tenemos un exponente impar
dejen repetir lo que acabo de decir si
tenemos por ejemplo dejan ponerlo aquí
se me ocurre tomar una equis con un
exponente más pequeño imagínate en menos
x esto elevado al cubo bueno nosotros
sabemos que esto es exactamente lo mismo
que el negativo de x elevado al cubo
sabemos que te va a dar un valor
negativo de la misma manera si tenemos
por ejemplo
2x elevado a la potencia esto elevado a
la potencia de 7 es lo mismo que menos x
séptima es decir me voy a tomar el
negativo de x elevado a la potencia 7 y
esto porque el exponente es impar y tú
puedes intentarlo con cualquier valor
que quieras por ejemplo si éste fuera
menos uno menos uno elevado a la séptima
potencia va a ser lo mismo que el
negativo de uno elevado a la séptima
potencia entonces con esto déjame
escribir acá arriba que menos x elevado
a la potencia 11 va a ser exactamente lo
mismo lo voy a poner con su respectivo
color que menos x elevado a la potencia
11 el negativo de x elevado la potencia
11 y bueno como está multiplicando al
menos 10 lo voy a poner entre paréntesis
entonces éste se va y de igual manera
aquí tengo más o menos x
esto elevado a la potencia 9 pero ya
sabemos que como el 9
entonces me va a quedar menos x elevado
a la potencia 9 dicho otra manera aquí
estoy escribiendo que vamos a hacer
primero los exponentes y al final le
ponemos un signo negativo al principio
así que éste también se va y bueno
después tengo menos menos equis esto
elevado la potencia 3 bueno este también
lo podemos reemplazar por menos x
elevado a la tercera potencia lo voy a
poner entre paréntesis para no afectar
este signo y al final tengo al 7
multiplicando a menos x así que aquí no
hay nada que hacer así lo voy a dejar y
ahora si tenemos menos 10 que multiplica
al negativo de x elevado a la 11 bueno
eso es lo mismo que negativo por
negativo de positivo entonces me
quedaría 10 x elevado a la potencia 11 y
después tengo
el negativo de x 9 bueno negativo por
positivo es negativo x elevado a la
potencia 9 y después me quedaría menos -
x cúbica eso me va a dar más x cúbica
por los signos y después tengo más x
menos es menos 7x y ahora observa si te
das cuenta todos estos son muy parecidos
a los que tenía que arriba solamente que
se le cambió el signo a cada uno de
ellos todos tienen el signo contrario
entonces esto es como siempre ha puesto
lo mismo que el negativo de h de x
entonces es menos hdx observa esto es lo
mismo que agarrar a hdx y multiplicar
cada uno de estos términos por menos 1
llegaríamos a esta expresión de trabajo
dicho otra manera empecé con h de menos
x
y obtuve y obtuve menos hd
lo que quiere decir que la función h es
impar
y una marca reveladora de todo esto que
podrías ver desde el principio es que
esta función está hecha por la suma de
un montón de funciones impares por
ejemplo aquí tenemos menos 10 x a la 11
y como x a la 11 tiene un exponente
impar hace que este pedazo de aquí sea
una función impar menos 10 x a la 11 por
sí sola es una función impar lo mismo
pasa con ex a la 9 como tenemos un
exponente impar esta función por sí sola
es una función impar lo mismo pasa con x
pública como tenemos un exponente en par
hace que esto sea una función impar y lo
mismo pasa con 7x como tenemos un
exponente impar
entonces ésta sería una función impar
por sí sola y entonces si sumas un
montón de funciones impares vas a
obtener una función impar
todos estos términos tienen exponente
impar lo que los hace funciones impar
muy bien ahora pensemos en fx vamos a
pensar en f de menos x lo voy a poner
aquí
efe de menos x y quién va a ser
efe de menos x bueno pues esto va a ser
lo mismo que menos 7 que multiplica a
menos x esto elevado a su vez a la sexta
potencia más déjame ponerlo así más 3
que multiplica a menos x elevado a la
cuarta potencia menos 9 que multiplica a
menos x elevado al cuadrado más 8 más 8
ahora bien esto va a ser lo mismo que
menos 7 y después tengo un número
negativo elevado a la sexta potencia
como la potencia es par entonces esto va
a ser lo mismo que un número positivo
entonces esto será igual que menos 7
a la sexta potencia más tres y va a
pasar lo mismo aquí tengo un número
negativo elevado a la cuarta potencia
bueno esto es lo mismo que la versión
positiva de ese mismo número elevado a
la cuarta potencia porque todos los
signos se cancelan entonces tendremos 3x
elevado a la cuarta potencia y aquí para
sería lo mismo tendría menos 9 y aquí
tengo un número negativo elevado al
cuadrado es lo mismo que la versión
positiva de ese número elevado al
cuadrado por ejemplo piensa en menos 3
menos 3 al cuadrado
es lo mismo que 3 al cuadrado por lo
tanto aquí me quedarían menos 9 x
cuadrada más
entonces observa llegamos de nuevo a efe
de x podemos decir que f de menos x es
un mismo que f de x y bueno por lo tanto
fx es una función par y realmente no te
debe sorprender mucho todo esto porque
si observas fx se obtiene de la suma de
muchas funciones pares de un montón de
funciones pares cada una de estas
funciones es simétrica al eje james y
entonces cuando las sumas vas a obtener
una función para una función par que
está hecha de un montón de términos que
tienen grados pares sexto grado un
cuarto grado segundo grado y grado cero
puedes ver esto como grado cero bien
ahora pensemos qué pasa con gdx y bueno
si observas gtx que ya casi no se ve
porque está un poco enterrada por aquí
está gdx la puedes ver y decir
gtx está formada por una función para
aquí tengo otra función par y también
tenemos funciones impares aquí tengo una
función impar x elevado a la tercera de
potencia y una función impar x elevado a
la primera potencia entonces gtx es una
mezcla de funciones pares e impares
por lo tanto podrías asegurar que ésta
no va a ser ni pan ni impar y bueno esto
podemos probarlo es más vamos a hacerlo
aquí si queremos trabajar con gdx déjame
ponerlo con su color entonces vamos a
trabajar con g de menos
x hija de menos x quien va a ser va a
ser lo mismo que 3 que multiplica a
menos x esto elevado a la cuarta
potencia y después tengo menos 10 que
multiplica a menos x esto elevado a la
tercera potencia después tengo
- x esto a su vez elevado al cuadrado
después tengo menos menos x muy bien
pero menos x elevado a la cuarta
potencia a quien va a ser igual
bueno como tenemos un exponente par
recuerda que esto lo podemos reemplazar
por equis elevado a la cuarta potencia
después tengo menos x esto a su vez
elevado a la tercera potencia sabemos
que esto es lo mismo que el negativo de
x elevado a la tercera potencia y
después aquí tengo menos x esto elevado
al cuadrado bueno eso lo podemos ver
como x elevado al cuadrado y al final
bueno al final tengo a menos x entonces
esto va a ser igual a quien a 3x a la
cuarta potencia aquí tengo menos por
menos es más
10x kubica y después tengo más x
cuadrada y aquí tengo menos por menos es
más más
ahora observa esto en definitiva no es
gdx porque si observas le cambiamos el
signo a los términos impares le
cambiamos el signo a los términos
impares y tampoco es menos gdx porque
solamente le cambiamos el signo a los
términos impares le cambiamos el signo a
este ya este pero no a los términos
pares entonces en definitiva no es que
de x ni tampoco es menos gdx entonces
ésta podemos decir que no es par ni
impar y hemos acabado